a new speaker called home pod iOS 11 for
the iPhone and iPad a new iPad pro a new
iMac pro and finally a new Apple watch
OS in a two-and-a-half-hour keynote
today at an annual Developers Conference
Apple announced a long list of new
products don't worry I've got everything
you need to know about them in under
three minutes
number one the home pod Apple's rival to
the Amazon echo but unlike the echo or
the Google home Apple is promising a
superior audio experience centered
around music and yes you can control it
with your voice it has an array of six
microphones that you summon with hey
Siri play my favorites Siri will be able
to tell you the news weather sports
scores set a timer and more when's it
coming this December for three hundred
and fifty dollars number 2 iOS 11 in
messages you'll be able to send money to
a friend control center has been
overhauled with access to more features
and there's a new do not disturb mode
for driving that will mute notifications
when you're in the car those all may
seem very simple but Apple did give us a
glimpse of the future with its AR kit
the software available only to
developers will let apps overlay objects
in the real world
when's the software coming it will be
available to the public this fall number
three a new iPad pro with a new 10.5
inch screen the iPad pro has a wider
software and hardware keyboard it also
has a faster screen refresh rate up to
120 Hertz a tan a 10x processor plus iOS
11 has new iPad specific features that
make it a lot more like a real computer
there's an app switcher a new file
system and the ability to drag files
between apps when's it coming
the new iPad will begin shipping next
week the new features in iOS 1011 will
be an update in the fall number for new
Macs the biggest Mac headline the iMac
pro it has a 5k display a new Space Gray
body and keyboard up to an 18 core
processor and killer graphics when's it
coming in December for $5,000 coming for
less cash and right now refreshed IMAX
and map
of pros the new iMacs have been updated
with 43 percent brighter screens and
have faster Intel processors as for the
new Mac software mac OS high sierra is
set to release to everyone this fall it
includes new safari photos and mail
features
number 5 watch OS for the main screen
will now have Siri predictions like
traffic and meeting info when you need
it it can also communicate with some new
gym equipment like treadmills and
ellipticals oh yeah and there's a new
watch face with Woody from Toy Story
sounds like Apple wants you to buy an
Apple watch for your six-year-old when's
it coming this fall